my portfolio was just quite basic I
wanted to scale up and do big things
went to the crash course and thought
this is amazing I was like okay now I'm
going to go and try to find a deal
you've had to fight with the council
you've had to fight with Builders you've
had to fight through Co a large
commercial site like a shopping mall and
financing it myself did you have any
idea when you came to CR course how much
you would achieve in the last 3 4 years
can you say any of the tenants who've
approached me was it
[Applause]
confidential
so every week Cameron as you know I
interview somebody on winners on a
Wednesday yes and they're financially
free they become a millionaire whatever
it might be and I've been doing that for
six years however some of my viewers say
well where are they now you know all
those people that you interviewed three
years ago where are they now so I
interviewed you on winners on a
Wednesday about three years ago that's
correct yeah and uh I wanted to know
what you've been up to since and where
are you now so are you still in property
how much you making what's going down
yeah I'm still in property um I've got a
few things in the pipeline but yeah I've
been really busy with you know helping
family you know on a couple of projects
and stuff so and you know I've got a
land deal that's in Scotland um which
I'm waiting for the right moment to
start putting in for planning obviously
finishing off things in Doncaster which
you'll be aware of um which took me a
bit longer changed a bit of a strategy
decided to go with something that's um
really highend from what I originally
was going to do which has worked out
great and I've got two deals right now
in the pipeline well possibly um another
one as well one's uh two mid Terraces
north of England with a commercial unit
in the middle large car park um which
we're going to hopefully develop the car
park as well and the commercial and the
two interes into Apartments you know
like one one-bedroom apartments HMO are
great but they involv a a bit of
management and you know so I thought go
for self-contained kind of luxury one
bit bedroom apartments that can be
structured in a way and built in a way
that we can add a bit of luxury and not
having to deal with all the bills and
paying everything looking at my
experience with hmos now as well and I'm
thinking let's do something where bit of
a single L but on a kind of for a single
person that's nice and luxurious and not
have the responsibilities of all the
bills and especially in this current
market yes one of the things you're
amazing at is problem solving and the
deals that you've been tackling and
taking on buying and and flipping are
some of the most Troublesome properties
you've had to fight with the council
you've had to fight with builders and
contractors you've had to fight through
covid um but it's it's paying off now
yeah definitely it's not easy and I
think the the mindset you have to kind
of adopt to the problems is just don't
give up work at it you will find a
solution and sometimes it's little steps
that resolve the bigger problems yeah
and and I think you have to be just
really determined and there's solutions
for everything I think there's three
solutions for every problem no matter
three solutions yes why do you say that
okay three solutions all right there's
one solution that's probably quite
difficult there's a second solution that
might be easier and then there's one
solution that is just phenomenal and
it's finding the one that's phenomenal
and it just takes a bit of time but most
people will see a problem and they'll
just say there's no solution but you're
saying oh there's loads of solutions
yeah yeah there is there's always a
solution you know it's a case of what
one's going to be the most cost
effective what one's going to work with
this development you know and what's
going to be the easiest you know and and
and I think you know coming across
problems and learning how to deal with
them is the key you've bought a couple
of big commercial properties very
recently yes I have tell me about them
okay the first one is the two end
interes with the commercial aspect now
are plan we've got preapp in for that
you know is to to turn it into the
apartments right and we've got a large
car park which is a bit of a Troublesome
site you know um with lots of issues
vandalism the council people dumping
stuff there uh so Council would love to
see something done with it which is
where we step in and hopefully you know
we'll be able to improve that site
second site is um it's a a large
commercial site you know like a shopping
mall um with a large car park that's big
project that one yes I love oh mate
could you tell I was envious when you
showed me that yeah I how are you
financing this you know I'm saying like
do you need any Finance do you need any
partners and you're like n I'm good I'm
financing it myself yes um I'm financing
it myself and yeah it's interesting
because you know I'm I'm loving the
commercial aspect of it cuz I've done it
in one of my previous projects in
Doncaster you know getting the right
commercial tenant with my experience in
retail and Commercial kind of stuff I
think yeah finding a spot and thinking
yeah what's missing maybe a coffee shop
you know maybe you know a spa you maybe
a retail unit but then again you know
people are saying the High Street is
gone commercial units are so cheap but
finding the right kind of commercial
unit and repurposing it for one of the
service Industries yeah you that's where
the big money is yeah like that site
that you're getting for 275 Grand so it
is yes yes how are you buying a mall for
275 Grand and it's huge yes and you're
already being approached by some of the
biggest companies in the world yes um
and and and I think you know that can
you say any of the tenants who've
approached you or is it confidential
well I can tell you on is like
Morrison's daily who are expanding you
know all over the UK are they Keen to be
tenants of yours yes massively very keen
yes I've got their emails and the chat
are they Keener to be your tenant or are
you Keener to have them as a tenant to
be honest I'm not really bothered
why because I've been in retail you know
I've been in retail for 33 years I sold
my retail business in October the large
ones were the guys that were put us
independence out of business so I know
that that site if one of the bigger
companies doesn't take it I'd be happy
to give it to an independent operator
that's competent and is aware of what
they're doing you know why not you know
because you know from my experience the
you know the the larger kind of
multinational comp IES they start
dictating to you we want this X Y and Z
why should I have to do exactly what
they say I want to be in control here
and if I can give an independent person
an opportunity knowing that they're
interested means that they'll be
suitable for an independent operator as
well and I've seen some of your shops
and I've seen some of your buildings and
we've we've been out and your tenants
are killing it yeah you know your
tenants are making good money running
their business yeah and and it makes a
massive impact on Independent you know
the Independent Business should be
supported you know yeah and it changes
communities as well and people can you
explain how commercial leases are
important and how they affect commercial
valuations what the link is yeah so
commercial lease is generally you know
is a f which a full repair inure lease
which the your tenant is responsible for
maintaining that building that unit as
far as when it goes to any repairs so
you give them a you know a building
that's in a condition
they have to return it to you at the end
of their lease or if you choose to end
the lease or they choose to to end it
commercial leases can be something that
you can sit down with your solicitor and
kind of design it around what suits you
yeah um you know you know I've got 10 21
year lease he's delighted you know um
he's quite happy with everything he has
to contribute to the insurance of the
building as well every year and the the
thing with commercial leases is that
it's not like when you have a tenant in
the residential side if they don't pay
their rent in four weeks time you can
have them out yeah they have to leave
it's an easier process and you get to
keep the money so if you're rent your
commercial tenant is paying you £2,000 a
month that's yours you don't have to go
and paint the walls and do maintenance
internally also you can have a service
charge if it's part of a a larger
building that the the tenant has to
commercial tenant has to contribute to
keep the fabric of the building in good
condition so yeah it's I think it
commercial strategies are great and in
terms of the valuation you're not
guessing so much you kind of know what
the evaluation be pretty much exactly
yeah because when you've got a tenant on
a long lease you can approach you know a
bank and say okay I've got 21 year lease
they're paying me £25,000 a year and
they'll be like okay so generally you
know for
£25,000 you know about 200 this is just
rough be
250,000 commercial valuation sometimes
it's a little bit more depending on the
area yeah depending on the yield
depending on the quality of the tenant
and also there's another aspect to the
commercial side is as well sometimes
having uh you know a commercial property
that is vacant has actually got more
value than when it's rented out so how
you come across this analogy of this is
that if it's in a location that you
maybe get one of the larger commercial
tenants that are worldwide or
national there's a possibility they
could move in there so you've got an
empty commercial property you can
possibly keep it empty or you know some
people will say oh you know I don't want
to keep it empty I want to get tenant in
there quickly and you might rush into I
I'll make it to a barber shop or I'll
make it to a hairdress or or a retail
unit convenience store whatever and you
might take on a an independent person
and just you possibly get a little less
you probably get a quarter of what you
could get yeah so when that property is
vacant if a surveyor commercial surveyor
comes out he'll say oh well there's a
possibility that of the bigger companies
National companies will take that unit
so they can actually give you a
valuation on the assumption that this
would be suitable right for one of the
bigger National companies you know I
learned this from uh commercial surveyor
that I met and she went through the
process explained it to me and and I was
like that's crazy that's great though
how are you getting in touch with these
bigger tenants so Morrison for example
how did that connection happen tell me
the story okay that happened through an
agent that you know we were looking at
um you know we were looking at a
commercial building and he said that
there's been some interest just as a you
know I got on well with the agent and he
said as a sideline to this commercial
unit that we have got this uh you know
maron's da that are interested in the
site obviously you have to possibly
design it in a way that it'll be
suitable for them you might have to do
some shots so the surve tipped you off
yeah and the Sur is a fan of me as well
right yes he is of course everybody in
the industry is a fan of me of course
which was great cuz yeah you know was a
young surveyor wanted to know well how
did you get into this I'm Blown Away by
what you're thinking of doing with my
business partner was there George as
well he was just intrigued about our
journey property journey I told him a
little bit about yourself and my journey
with Samuel Leeds my training and he
went away his break and went onto the
you know onto your website and had to
look at some of the stuff that and he
was like I spent my whole lunch just
online even your tenants you've told all
your tenants about they up oh yeah we
watch you on YouTube now like all the
people that you keep introducing to me
as well now there's some great content
out there you know for people that are
maybe interested you know have a look at
it you know go go further get educated
you know do one of the courses come to
garage course yes well that's where you
started 100% I mean you came to when
when when did you first come to the
crash course was it 2020 I think I think
it might have been around 2020 yeah
beginning it was 2020 yeah yeah it was
did you have any idea when you came to
crash course how much you would achieve
in the last sort of three four years no
no idea no cuz you had a few properties
yes I did yeah a few uh sort of just
normal B toet properties and then you
refinanced those yeah it was my you know
portfolio was just quite basic bu toet
portfolio how many properties did you
have when we met at that time I had four
five properties five BCT properties in
Scotland in a lovely part of Scotland
what did you think about at the crash
course and generally because you I know
you through the academy and I'm talking
about refinancing and taking your Equity
put into bigger stuff like was that like
an ARA moment was that something you
were planing to do anyway was that a
fear was there a bit of fear there well
before I joined the Academy I was you
know looking at it I didn't know the
process I wasn't sure there wasn't a
great deal of information out there and
you know I was thinking and I got some
advice of some people they said oh you
could refinance your portfolio but I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
once I done that do I do the same thing
I was doing before it's not that great
you know I don't think I wanted to scale
up and do bigger things and but I didn't
have the confidence to do it so when I
joined the crash course you know I still
was like okay I I need to go and find
out and get some knowledge and you know
with the experience I've got already I
want to be a professional property
developer and look at all my options
joined you know went to the crash course
and thought this is amazing loved the
environment loved being around people
that were you know really motivated in
property and you know at the crash
course I ended up on the stage got one
of the best deals and that's where it
started from how long was it after the
crash course when you found your first
deal I think when I went back from the
crash course that was me joined the
academy at the crash course straight
away he was like bang yeah yeah that was
it I was like okay now I'm going to go
and do my homework I'm going to go and
try to find a that's what I did I went
out to Doncaster looked at a a little
HMO and it was one of these online
agents went there it looked nothing like
the pictures it was a shambles and I
thought gosh this is such a
disappointment came all this way couple
of agents who were showing it on behalf
of the the vendor listen why don't you
come and have a look at something else
we've got a friend that's got this big
commercial property I was like okay he
goes it's a little walking distance and
then maybe we'll go for lunch or
something that sounds good
went along and it's this and I'm like he
goes the vendor will meet you and I was
goes okay cool we'll meet the vendor and
I met the vendor and and I was like
looking like where's this HML that I'm
looking at and he showed me this office
block and I was like okay he's like do I
come in I was like just overwhelmed by
the size of it and he goes here it is
and I was like okay I goes listen I'm
going be bit out of my comfort zone here
you're wanting like 312k for this I
haven't got that money and how am I
going to erase it and he's like look
you've got a bit of experience he goes
we all start off somewhere M if you're
interested and I was like I don't think
I can do this you know I was like I
really appreciate your time but I think
this is just totally out of my league
and I was looking at this office block
and you know what am I going to do with
it you know and need's oh we've outlin
plans here and there looking at the
plans I was looking at them and I just
still couldn't make head or toe cuz
there was a couple of options cuz it was
outline planning so I was like okay and
I was like listen really appreciate time
but I think this is just too much you
seen it overwhelmed then what happened
so obviously I was like this was too
much for me I can't do this on the
Launchpad wrote down all the things we
were going to do what we hunting I
thought you know something I'm going to
go for it found him back and thought
yeah do you know something I'm going to
do this and you know I spoke to Anthony
I spoke to you know yourself and you
know a few other people and I was really
excited and I thought okay I've got the
back up here don't know how I was going
to do it no idea how I'm going to back
hadn't even approached the refinance
situation but I'd spoken somebody had
said to me go was go you know there's a
guy that can do it for you and I was
like okay cuz I hadn't got that far in
the academy to meet anybody that's to do
with Finance or whatever and he says
he'll charge a percentage of the
portfolio it's going to cost you cost
you about 8 n Grand whatever and and I
say okay whatever and I started that
process before I had got any education
and it all went wrong he made some
mistakes and stuff I don't know what
happened I get the refinance you know at
the beginning of the stages so I thought
sugar you know I've give my word to the
vendor now and I obviously approached
Anthony and spoke to yourselves and I
said well you know we've got a team you
know that can help you with that Sophia
Jones was was fantastic she's like look
I can help you with this cuz she was on
stage you know Point got chat her she
refinanced my whole
portfolio it was brilliant I think it
cost me about 1,500 quids so my Academy
fee was already paid with just one
contct and that was it and I remember
speaking to Anthony again finances came
through I'm going to get it you know and
the vendor was really patient he was
fantastic you know cuz he really wanted
me to take that step into doing bigger
thingss so that was where it started I
remember the still to this day you know
giving Anthony the figures course can
you please check this because I don't
think this is right I looked at the
worst scenarios just with the five bed
HMO the 10 bed HMO the retail unit and I
goes is that right he goes no that's
right he goes what do you think he goes
That's phenomenal yeah and he was really
interested in it himself he like well if
you don't want it having people to just
say is this good have I missed anything
are there any blind spots it's so
valuable so you bought that property
then straight off the back of the crash
course pretty much you're on the academy
what happened with it and what did you
do with it okay then I had outlined
planning I started um looking at the
process and I thought okay I've bought
it now got a little bit of money but not
enough to do it you know and what do I
do I'm going to have to raise some money
so raised some money from family and
friends and started the process and Co
kicked in which was just massive you
know I had a contractor that was doing
work for me um you know over a period of
time now the project that was 18 months
ended up like 24 months even longer and
you know his guys were leaving him
materials were up 40% it was unbel
believable and I was like gosh you know
I'm coming here every week and things
aren't being done so he didn't have the
guys he didn't ask me for more money and
the guys he was getting just weren't
doing the work to the quality or the
finish that was expected and I wasn't
aware of all the issues because I didn't
have any control over this you know
multitrade company that I'd employed
because they had a private um Clerk of
works that would sign off at every stage
so I wasn't I was just told it's getting
done I can't see what's behind the you
know the sockets of fire protected at
the back and all are fire collar you
know and the waste pipes and the
drainage cuz things were just getting
covered on then the contractor was
saying to the carer works we'll just
send you pictures so things were really
bad what did you do did you have to get
rid of them yeah I had to get just F
them yeah and I thought they were they
were willing to PL on long but there
were like couple of guys materials
weren't there i' paid for stuff that
wasn't you know they just couldn't do it
because of to be honest costs has went
up so much as well at this point though
did you feel were you like afraid did
you think that this might just all go
your entire life savings from the prop
gone I was like you know this is
massive had a big effect on me
personally on my you know it was a lot
of pressure horrible horrible horrible
situation and I thought but no you know
I'm not going to give up here I've had
enough you know and at the same time
when I when I'd start what I putting for
planning for Penthouse Apartments came
across so many issues with that it was
Within of a listed building you know was
I going to get the cherry on the cake
you know was having to build on top of
this building had not been done in the
area before I had everything against me
came up with a meeting with the
conservation officer he said nope you're
not getting anything here and I was like
come on no please come out and have a
look you got that pressure you got
planning permission saying no obviously
you've got the outline planning for the
initial yes but the build costs were
going up couldn't get the extra planning
for the apartments that you wanted in
lockdown fired the bill ERS yeah at this
point I was by myself yeah and I thought
I'm going to have to get on the tools
I'm going to have to live on site I'm
going to have to do based in Glasgow do
you what I mean 4-Hour drive and um the
conservation officer came up and I
showed him persuaded him with um you
know local architect you know Shane
Marsh building link design who's
phenomenal he arranged the meeting and
gave him the sketch and and the
conservation officer said yeah I think
we can do something here and wow so what
was that with that just pure persistence
persistence to get the conversation to
get the meeting yes but also using my
little knowledge that I had of the the
massing issues I've worked on grade one
grade two listed buildings in Scotland
all period properties so I knew that
there were certain things that I would
have to satisfy him with yes so I'd done
in my homewor beforehand right you know
so but there's no guarantee there's not
with planning with' getting planning cuz
the council can just say no we don't
like it no that's it and they they were
very worried about the the listed
building wer they they didn't want it to
they didn't want your new big high
Penthouse to overlook the listed
building how did you get around that how
did you persuade the council and the
conservation officers to agree so when I
took him onto the roof it was a flat
roof but there was a section where it
dropped down about 3 and 1/2 4T so it
was sunk yeah so I thought okay I goes
listen you know why can't I build
something and drop it in there cut a
large hole in the building and drop
two-tier pre-cast staircase connecting
it to the penthouse within interal
building and the conservation officer
said he go I was wondering why you know
your 5 bed and 10 bed HMO you changed
the whole
layout and kept original staircase he go
it makes yes he goes this makes sense
yeah he goes I like the concept and I
basically wanted to do it so it didn't
look like an extension pre-cast
staircase made out of concrete craned in
brought in dropped in I did I had to do
myself things were really bad you know
tight and with the help of an engineer
and my guys I've got quite a bit of
knowledge when it comes to doing you
know building Works anyway and I came up
with a design of full um you know full
ceiling Heights at 2 M 4 and not
affecting the building next to me right
smart yes so you got the planning yes
how long did it take to get at the
planning okay the planning process took
quite a while cuz obviously you know Co
had kicked in everything and things were
difficult and it took me about probably
about five six months okay six months
wasn't bad what the outline figures in
so you bought it for 312 yes and at that
point you didn't really know what you
were doing bit out your depth oh totally
out my depth but then you went through
the process you persisted you continued
to gain knowledge you got planning how
much did the entire refurb and the
construction cost of everything that you
built okay so I was looking about
roughly about 850 to 900,000 including
the purchase yes including the purchase
okay cuz I was the reason why you know I
was going to be struggling I wasn't sure
what valuation I was going to get what I
decided to do was try to go as high end
and go for a small pull of the market
which is professionals I was up against
it people said that area was never going
to be I me you received more criticism
and skepticism from everybody even like
the rent yes you're never going to be
able to rent those rooms out in
Doncaster the HM Market saturated but
you went down the co- living route yes
high end yes High refurb yep so so the
refurb is it was what 5 600 Grand then
just for the refb about 600k yeah 600k
plus the so You' talking yeah 900 Grand
all in that's a lot of money yes so when
I thought okay and people you're never
going to get a commercial valuation as
well you know you know Harley wel at 247
proper who is a fantastic agent in the
area who was very supportive through the
whole process I had a conversation with
him early on you know and I said do you
think there's a market for I'm going to
create a product for you can you get me
the clients he because I think he goes I
can do it yeah and I was okay are you
sure and I've met the clients now yes
I've met all the tenants yes
professionals you know that are willing
to pay a bit more than what the a lot
more over the for a premium product for
a premium product so if you spent 600
Grand on the refurb plus 312,000 for the
purchase you're talking about $900 all
in yes you then got a new valuation yes
and the banks were happy to lend yes
what did the new valuation come in it
was at 1.7 million respect yeah so you
pulled out you and what what loan divide
did they give you 75% and what was the
bank shawbrook shawbrook bank gave you a
75% Lo to Value that's 1.7 million so
that means you must have pulled out more
money than you put in yeah 1.7 million
times 75% so you pulled out about 1.27
yes wow deal of this and and you ended
up getting property developer of the
Year Awards that's right on the academy
and I still felt that oh you know I
didn't do that great why did you feel
that I think cuz when I originally
costed it you know with the the
contractor basically from what I learned
with the Academy I used all that
information to project how the project
the costings but I suppose I felt I
didn't do very well you know because it
wasn't what I initially set out to do
yeah and to achieve you were a bit
annoyed of yourself for letting the the
budget go over a little yeah but then I
couldn't stop Co no you can't you know I
couldn't stop the material costs the
labor issues you know and that's why I
was you know living on site you know
working doing the most it worth it yeah
110 how much profit did did that deal
make then I'm probably you know about
800 odk that's incredible obviously we
leave some money in the pot you know
with the refinance and stuff so about
800 Grand almost a million yeah profit
on one deal in D if you take long to
value what you've left in the pot you
know as well and but really to be honest
I wasn't too concerned I was just happy
to get out and compl the project
complete the project cuz people were
saying to me you know stick it an
auction you're not going to survive this
you know that you know how are you even
going to get valuation there was a lot
of procrastination from people and
saying oh you know you know even to
people that are very experienced in that
area landlord so you'll never get those
rents it's impossible you are getting
those rents speaks for itself and if you
weren't getting those rents you wouldn't
get the value cuz how when the value
comes out I mean What's the total rent
roll across the entire building I think
it's what in the region of 15 and a half
think was it 16 was about 16 and a half
Grand including the retail unit yeah
sorry yeah yeah cuz you've got 21 rooms
yes over four flats and then you've also
got the retail unit which is massive by
the way and they love it it's they love
it and it's just un introductionary rent
at the moment you know cuz you who's the
ten in there what's the name um it's um
Aram and AK there's a few people aqu
that are involved in it and they're on a
21-year lease yes fully repairing
insured lease and they've got the you
know they've got the biggest world food
store in South Yorkshire at the moment
with so is that what you used when you
made that 800 Grand is that what you
used to then start buying other
properties other commercial stuff yes
yes okay so you're just snowballing yeah
so now you know I'm in a position where
I I want to be buying you know the I
went through bridging as well you know I
got money from friends and family so I
went went through the whole process and
then using you know a top Commercial
Bank so I thought okay how much money
have I got here once I give people back
money that I own bits and pieces and
stuff where I'm at and you know I'd like
to go and get some small projects and if
I can buy some of them out right and
finance them you know refurb and add
value and looking at the current market
have lots of different strategies you
know sites that I've got the worst
scenario the best scenarios um so yeah
and you've bought some properties for
your family members as well right yeah
I've helped helped my mom move from our
family home um to move near me in that
process was you know it was our family
home for gosh um over 40 years and you
know in Scotland uh in a in a lovely
part of the West End Glasgow and you
know got the you know the highest U mid
Terrace ever to be sold in that area and
then I brought her nearer to myself and
I reformed that from for my mom within 6
to 8 weeks got moved in she loves it
that's nice yeah that's what it's all
about really isn't it you know I was I
was involved with other family members
and other things as well helping them
along in their Journey as well letting
them to do more themselves and just if
they come across any complex issues
helping them out you know what so many
people when they become super successful
in especially in property in property
development they keep they were card so
close to their chest they don't want to
they would never come on YouTube like
this and share what they're doing but I
think the one of the things I love about
you is you've got a really giving heart
you've helped so many people on the
academy you know being being passing on
your information helping your family
there there has been a lot of people in
the journey that I've tried my best you
know to help them and um yeah I
definitely do enjoy because people don't
want to share knowledge nobody wants to
tell you how to do it and you know you
know when I years ago when I started off
as a novice you know there was no
information available no wanted the ones
that were successful didn't want to
share anything now if I can help someone
and possibly have share an experience
that I've been through that is you know
can save them some money some heartache
some hassle I I'll help everyone that
com my way what do you think about some
of the commercial properties that I've
bought last year oh phenomenal you
showed me them now and I just think yeah
that's just on another level I think
you've structured some great deals
together yeah it's really interesting
and can't wait to see you do the you
know put them through as what plans
you've got and I I can't wait for us I
have a feeling we're going to be doing
things together you're coming down to
the academy dinner in a couple of weeks
which will be
great coming down to my house Cate coach
performance program you you're excited
about that yeah I I've I've kind of held
off yeah from doing it I should have
done it a long time ago um but then I
thought you know I really like to come
and see you yeah it's part of the
academy to do it yeah I know it's been a
while but you know it's took me a while
to get where I'm going
and I think you know I want to get my
get value from where I'm at now bring as
much as I can't oh now we're peers now
now we're peers now What's um what would
you say your purpose for all of this is
because you've had to fight some real
battles yeah um what is it that keeps
you going through the tough times you
know what keeps me going is that I have
got you know I've got a lot of things I
want to do I want to change the world in
my own little way and that is you know
what really drives me and my big why is
that you know when there's people that
don't have clean drinking water children
that spend all day going up and down
Hills and you can't get an education cuz
they can't have clean drinking water
that' cost 150 quid to set up a well in
their Village or you know their Town
wherever we are and just you know
there's so much you know poverty in the
world and if I can make lots of money
and if I can use my money to change
somebody's life and for me looking at
these people and I've got family and
I've got friends that are involved in
lots of projects I can help just by
giving them money towards it and I can
see the pictures I can see the videos
but I actually want to physically go
there MH and I want to be building you
know those homes for them or I want to
be helping in the orphanages you know
bringing my skill set yeah physically
instead of just looking at the videos
and the pictures yeah you know and using
my own money that I want to generate
through property there comes a point
where you've got a nice home you've got
nice cars you've got all the material
things you want but it doesn't really
satis it doesn't satisfy me you know I I
think being driven with that big why
that you can change somebody's life with
very little money yeah it is for me it's
phenomenal have you got any plans to go
anywhere yes
to go away um I want to I'm want to go
away and have a family holiday which is
long due yeah well if you fancy coming
out to Uganda with us bro I'd love to we
should make that happen we've just built
a hospital we built two schools
thousands of kids I can't wait I love
that opportunity because now I sold my
business in October because remember
like when I was on this property journey
I still had a retail business I used to
get up at 5:00 in the morning I remember
I used to work 4 days there with my
staff you know and then then I I would
make my way to Doncaster stay on site
three four days a week did you get the
sale you wanted for the business to be
honest I'm happy you know because retail
is really difficult yeah um you happy to
be out of it I'm happy to be out of it
full-time in property fulltime in
property millionaire now coming to
Uganda oh can't wait and I tell you
something as well Cameron the work that
you've done i' I've seen your projects
you're making a massive difference in
the community is yes you're making money
I've met your tenants you're providing a
great service and a great product and
you that's enough you should be proud of
that yeah and and I think you know even
my commercial tenant I see how you know
you know the the project I helped him
with the commercial project with my
experience in retail for 33 years as
well it was something lovely he said to
me he goes you know with your hands he
goes you've changed so many people's
lives and I was like what are you
talking about I don't get it no you did
this no he goes no this has came through
you if you hadn't gave us this
opportunity you hadn't walked us through
the process of getting this commercial
unit ready all the legislation all the
things to do it on a level that is you
know professional and different from
everywhere I changed that whole street
yeah you did I did and you know it
speaks for itself and they got a
shopping mall yeah and all kinds of
other stuff but I tell you something
though like those tenants they love you
they love you so and when the builders
had to leave site you were on your hands
and knees yes so you deserve every
success you've got and I've loved
working with you no thank you likewise I
couldn't have done it without the
support from yourself Samuel Anthony all
the lads all the team Ricky the first
time I got on the stage Ricky Mandel on
the crash course you know and but uh I
definitely think you know that I got so
much from that experience love bro thank
you congratul you again thanks very much